[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 154 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I'm mock Mandal and I'm here with my
wonderful colleague that I forgot her
name hi mark how are you I didn't expect
this er positive response I'm good how
are you doing I'm good - alright we'll
mark this week we have G sweet yeah our
docket we have Alicia and Johanna
joining us this week which is really
great and before we get into that as
always we will start off with our cool
things of the week and we will end with
our question of the week and this
question comes all the way from mark
which is what if I want to write a code
sample with a link that opens the cloud
console and automatically clones a git
repository into cloud shell that was a
lot of alliteration yeah not a problem
at all there anyway so let's go ahead
and start out with our cool things of
the week and I want to start out by
giving a shout out to Sarah Robinson one
of our colleagues who posted up a great
post last week and she specifically
talks about classifying congressional
bills with machine learning you know
she's always looking for a good datasets
and she found this open source dataset
with 400,000 congressional bills and it
had like 20-plus data points for each
bill so she worked with out on doing
classifications and some of the data
points she lists she also lists her
process for training an auto ml natural
language model so she used that as her
tool and she talked about how she
evaluated it got predictions from it and
how you can use it and find the stuff
that she put together and play around
with it yeah shows she gives you all the
great information you need and you can
look this up and play around with the
code later if you'd like so check it out
so we actually mentioned this during the
podcast but it's the third installment
of the serverless from the ground-up
series by martin omander talking about
how to integrate google cloud with g
suite and this time they actually are
integrating cloud firestore into the mix
we'd some cloud functions and pops up
with the spreadsheet and all the other
good things to kind of expand on the set
of things that they were building
previously how to manage this document
system so well worth the read and we
also talked about it in the interview as
well so it's definitely a cool thing
agreed
another cool thing of the week is we're
going to include a link to this blog
post on how 20th Century Fox is using
machine learning to predict a movie
audience so this is very applicable for
anybody who's actually trying to
understand their core audience and they
specifically talked about the details on
how they built out their data pipeline
and
- this model that helps them understand
and predict what audiences will come out
and they explain how they did their
validation of this model as well and
just how valuable it's been for their
data teams and their marketing teams
have a greater insight into the audience
excellent yeah cool looking to that nice
also relevant for today there's a new
and improved G suite developer hub so if
you're looking to build integrations
with G suite either with other G suite
products or with cloud or all sorts of
other fun stuff there is a new hub that
you can get access to it which allows
you to get start quickly you can view
and manage your triggers you can view a
manager at maker apps see executions in
real time
also it's real pretty and then we want
to give a shout-out for last week's
Google doodle which included this really
adorable game with ghosts yes mark was
so excited about this it was the very
first multiplayer at Google doodle nice
which was super cool and it ran on top
of Google cloud platform I think it ran
really really well and also integrated a
good friend of mine Joseph Holly's
open-source project called open match
matchmaking if you still want to play
around with that we've got the link and
you can check it out
awesome before we run away to our
interview congratulations to Melanie she
has put up with me for a whole year at
this point
lots up there and she hasn't left yet so
that's a lot in therapy thank you very
much for leaving it's been fun it's been
a good year we've done a lot this year a
lot and we will talk more about that at
the end of the year - okay so mark I
think it's time for us to go talk with
Alicia and with Joanna let's do it well
I'm very excited today to have two
delightful people joining us we have
Joanna Smith and developer advocate for
G sweet as well as Alicia Williams team
mate of ours and cloud advocate as well
how you both doing it's good I can't
take Photoshop I'm great doing great
today excellent thank you so much for
coming and hanging out with us today we
talk to you all about G suite and all
the things involved in that before we do
that do you want to tell us a little bit
about who you are and what you're doing
Alicia you're sitting next to me why
don't you go ahead
yeah well I'm an advocate really focused
on data analysis discovering how they
can use both GC and GC P together to
solve their problems Joanna so I'm the
one who gets to be responsible for all
of the online content for both G suite
developers and also the power users
which is kind of like a new thing we're
doing it's just Alicia and I are trying
to make sure that anybody
can build it custom or productive
solution to make their day better and
not have to do that annoying thing you
get to do every Tuesday looks like ruins
your day like three hours in a
spreadsheet
what is the annoying thing that happens
every Tuesday I don't know maybe for you
it's like making all the links so that
all the people who are remote like me
and can't be in San Francisco to make a
podcast and you keep forgetting to make
them links and wouldn't it be great if
you could just like have your
spreadsheet of your calendar and be like
create link for remote podcasting and it
would do it for you helping automate and
simplify things for people
simplify your day so you can get your
job done well if there's anyone out
there who doesn't know what is gee sweet
well gee sweet do you use Gmail Melanie
maybe because Inbox might be going
somewhere and it might be using it right
now no so those apps actually that
collection of apps is called Qi sweet so
thinking Gmail also sheets stocks
calendar but it's not just like the docs
the real thing that we like to stress to
everybody is that GC is collaborative so
your whole suite of office and
productivity applications are meant to
be easy to use but also easy for
everyone else to use so you don't have
to download a file attach it to an email
send it over to somebody so they can
download it and then open it and then
edit it and send it back to you and you
hope that you understand what's going on
like we're trying to make working easier
through collaboration and that's why
it's so much fun for people like me all
by myself in a remote office not getting
to hang out in the back I feel like
we're gonna be talking about being
remote a lot yes I'm from Texas and I
like people and I know it I'm very proud
of my home really it's collaboration I'm
Jesus mate and then the other thing that
is my favorite about Jason is how
extensible it is like they designed this
product to be customizable so that
anybody could build anything with it
partly because we designed it for
ourselves first and then we started
selling it because people liked it but
also because it just it's nice to be
able to take something and tweak it and
add something to it so that you can get
your day to be a better day agreed and
so really I mean we're talking about all
the products that really fall into like
Google Drive what you're able to do the
Gmail and all these things which people
don't probably think about all that much
anymore because they're using them and
they're just sort of part of your life
it's just expected right you don't think
about it but it has to actually be
supported and built and started there's
a lot more than you think it does what I
think yes well okay what are some of the
favorite things you have about G suite
what are some of the favorite products
or a favorite functionality why are you
why do you like G suite
well I think everybody knows my favorite
product is sheets so I worked many years
as a program manager and I kind of got
to the point where I could do anything
in a Google sheet so much to the dismay
of my team anything mark I could track
anything I you know mail merge send
emails when things are over do a lot of
different things you can do from a sheet
even though it's not necessarily built
to be I think sheets is one of those
products that was built to do one thing
and now it does thousands of things
because it is so flexible so that's my
favorite product I gotta say I'm voting
for Gmail here not even inbox like just
old school classic Gmail because one I
don't know if you remember but way back
when when we all signed up for Gmail a
long time ago it was the first email
that was ever threaded so like your
reply to an email showed up next to the
email that you originally got and I
remember that just changing the way that
I view speaking to people in the
Internet I guess but the only thing is
that Gmail has grown and it's this like
powerhouse of great features to help you
keep your life in order and the way that
I can prove that is y'all can't deny
that Google runs on email everything
from like our bug systems RCL's our code
submissions are you know is the bill
broken this is all handled through email
and that's why we had to create our own
email like service because no others
could keep up and that's why it's been
such a successful email provider for so
many people and also for so many
companies so it's my favorite because
it's an oldie but goodie that sounds
good so I'll show you were talking about
how you could do like anything in sheets
how did you do anything in sheets like
you're talking about sending emails from
sheets like how it like there's no
there's no spreadsheet function for
sending email like in a cell is
or how does that work well that's more
of a recent addition to the types of
things that I can do but that's through
app script so app script is a JavaScript
based language I've been learning so I
spent many years just using the UI doing
everything you can do in sheets and Docs
and Gmail with the UI and then I started
discovering that behind a lot of the
spreadsheets and Doc's at work were
these scripts that other people had
written I started kind of dabbling in
those editing them when I needed to and
then finally decided it was time to
learn to write my own to do things that
no one else had written to do yeah it's
it's something that you can write
standalone scripts that call multiple
Docs and spreadsheets together to get
something done or you can have just
behind one spreadsheet you can use Apps
Script to automate many of the things
that happen in your spreadsheet or to
call out to other services to to bring
those into your spreadsheet as well is
there like a public spot for people to
share Apps scripts that they like to
write so that you like to write we have
a pretty active community across G+ also
across Stack Overflow and github but
there's also a marketplace where a lot
of companies will create applications
that they sell to other companies to
make days better and then you can also
you know put them up for free as well
like one of my favorite isn't actually
available I have to be clear about this
it was just written by someone on our
team and then like shared internally but
you could make it yourself as well is we
have a calendar and it's a team vacation
calendar and the way we manage it is not
by everyone putting their vacation on a
second calendar that is hard to remember
and like you don't really want to think
about but we have an app script that
runs every night at midnight and looks
at everyone's calendar and then copies
in the event called out-of-office or
vacation to the team vacation calendar
programmatically and easily how do I add
those are those the add-ons it's
actually different it's not different
but it is different and you're just
going to trust me on this as I explain
it so anybody can add Apps Script any
where pretty much they're great for
mainly the editors so Docs sheets slides
forums but also in drive themselves and
all Apps scripts are ran from drive
saved and drive and the editor you can
access by going to script.google.com but
you can also create a script inside of
us
cific sheet by clicking on tools and
script editor in there and that script
will then be bound to that sheet so when
you share the sheet the script goes with
it to other people as well that has its
own advantages verses like standalone
scripts and then add-ons are created
with Apps Script they're powered by Apps
Script but then add-ons can span over to
Gmail to calendar they're a little more
robust and then one of the great things
about add-ons is you write it all up
once and then Google does the hard work
of making it work for Gmail on web and
Gmail on mobile so Alicia you were
talking about learning like JavaScript
and Apps Script and playing with this
stuff a lot more how have you found the
editor experience cuz it's Joanna
touched on that a little bit like how is
that integrated IDE type thing how does
that work so for me it's basically the
difference between even starting to look
at it I didn't want to have to you know
install any packages on my computer or
decide on you know an IDE I didn't even
know what that stood for at the time so
having the editor in the browser is
really what made it so accessible to me
and you talked a little bit about how to
find kind of where people share these
things and we do have a lot of samples
in our documentation and on github but
you'll find that people share them all
over the place and just by using search
I tend to find I like to start out with
something so I have nothing to start out
from I'll just take a random script and
put it in there and then just start
editing away because I think it's really
helpful to have a place to start and so
there is a lot out there that you can
get you know maybe it's only 5% of the
way there but it gives you a place to
start and I find those actually on Stack
Overflow as well
there's Apps Script community there and
then we have a lot of actually Google
developer experts that blog about it and
it's really helped me I had to for demo
create a way to automatically submit to
a Google Form as part of the demo which
is not something you would typically do
typically would submit to the form but I
wanted to submit a lot of form responses
all at once in front of an audience and
I was actually able by you know using
search to find somebody that had done
something similar and it was an area
where just going to our documentation
because it wasn't a common use case I
was getting nowhere
so I was pretty excited and surprised to
find it and I was able to then build
that functionality into my demo so
that's great you know definitely the
same in terms of working with a blank
page just grabbing something something
to start out with it I definitely
respect and understand that
I know there are api's can tell us a
little bit about the api's oh the API
it's the api's are actually something I
haven't really delved into yet but I
think Joanna has I can touch on this
briefly basically we have so many api's
for so many services and as you would
expect we've got an API for sheets that
can basically provide all the
functionality that Apps Script provides
as well these are all REST API s and we
offer them through client libraries and
so many languages trying to make sure we
can support any kind of use case you
have as a developer but the other cool
thing about the API is is we have a lot
that are specifically really meant to be
used by a domain administrator or
somebody who's trying to like manage
their company and uses G suite the
enterprise side of it you know let's say
you're hiring people so you can put them
in and out of your system with the
people in the context API there's an
admin SDK that actually lets you do all
kinds of controls for your organization
but programmatically so you don't have
to do everything by like going into
Chrome and like clicking and then having
and then typing it's like wouldn't it be
great if you just had a list somewhere
and it all uploaded for you and so those
are really really cool that sounds like
a really great chance to discuss like
the differences between G suite as like
the free consumer products and like G
suite for business like what's the
difference is there well so at the core
they're not different like Gmail at
Google Gmail for somebody who buys G
suite and Gmail for any user out there
they're the same Gmail and all the
features of Gmail are there all along
but there are some things that are less
available we were talking about this
earlier today anyway
yeah I mean we both use Google Gmail at
work and then we use personal Gmail
accounts and yeah for the most part I
don't notice a huge difference but I'm
also not a domain admin and I think some
of the things Joanna mentioned are one
of the biggest differences when you're
running a company you need those
features to be able to you know manage
email retention or managed Drive files
across the company that you don't need
to as it can
Zoomer there's also some other products
that are for our enterprise customers
that were really trying to put out there
first with the enterprising yeah makers
a really good example yeah it's not
available to a consumer user of Gmail
but it is available to many of our
enterprise customers
what's that maker think of you had like
a UI visual way to write an app script
where you could like drag components and
connect them and the code would be
generated behind the scenes for you and
that's what a maker is so it's a really
great tool for a company that doesn't
want to spend money hiring custom
engineers to build solutions for them
and doesn't have a strong engineering
department but has people who are smart
and clever and can figure it out so it's
like a low code alternative to building
these kinds of solutions for yourself
it's also a great way for people like me
maybe that would have a sheet and a form
as an app and my she is my database to
kind of scale beyond that so app maker
you can have you know web forms and you
have a database on the back end but it's
a cloud sequel database so it's kind of
a different you know a v2 maybe of some
sort of app I start to build just using
Google Forms and Google sheets nice well
so we've talked a little bit about the
API as we've talked about the app
scripts can use some of these
extensibility features to integrate
between G sweet and GCP yeah so I say
yes and I also say please please do
because the way I see it G's it's
actually how people get their job done
and if you can make anyone's job easier
then the whole company becomes a lot
more productive and that's like my stick
and I it's what I'm out there and I'm
like tweeting and I'm working on and
your stick into it yeah but the other
thing is like let's say several teams
across your company all need to work
with the data inside of one of your
databases through JCP you don't want to
train them on how to interact with your
database especially if they don't have a
lot of experience it's too many teams
that's too much access right so you can
imagine using like a sheet as a
front-end where data can be pulled down
based upon certain parameters or like
what each team needs and then it can be
you know reuploaded from the sheet as
well but the sheet and the collaborative
and the protective features that are
built in by
fault becomes the interface for a lot of
other teams to work with data you're
responsible for yeah and I think I was
really excited at next this year one of
my teammates Gabe kind of sent out an
email saying hey I have this crazy idea
I want to build an end-to-end IOT app
where we build a device on stage and we
go through all the process to actually
have a UI front end to show people
what's happening with those devices and
he wanted to have both an angular front
end and a Sheetz front end and I was you
know cuz I left sheets I was intrigued I
said sheets I'm like the one person on
this team thread that left sheets so I
started talking to him about it and we
ended up working together and I was part
of that talk but what they did was build
a device using a Raspberry Pi so it was
taking in heart rate and temperature
information and then they had this fancy
angular front-end that was able to show
all the different devices in real time
what was happening but we also built
those sheets front-end and it was a
place that anybody on the team could
have pulled like timeslice data from our
database from our fire store database
pull it in be able to analyze it how
you're used to a sheets collaborate with
others on that data as well but then it
had a second function which was to
configure the devices so Gabe had said
like oh you know like you can configure
the devices in IOT core but I'm
imagining you know if you were going to
give a bunch of devices out to people at
a company you might have some staff do
that that weren't working in IOT core so
this was a way that those staff could
actually configure the devices using
cloud function so a cell in the she
could be updated that could trigger a
cloud function to be called and then
that would update IOT core with new
configuration so that's awesome yeah and
it was actually really easy to do so I
think I agreed to do it before I knew
like how hard it might be and then I got
really lucky
I got really lucky because there's
actually already a library that I found
that connects firestore
to Apps Script so this library using a
service account I could authenticate to
fire store I could edit my fire store
database all with Apps Script and so in
the end I had a few features in my front
ends so I could you know how the user
could put in a certain time slice and it
would pull that device
mint data back and show a graph in my
sheet I also had a way to update the
device metadata in firestore so say like
the name for the device and then also
the device configuration so the
configuration is actually stored on the
device not just in fire store and this
needs to be done through IOT core and so
this is the part where I could call a
cloud function just by you know I can
have a trigger on my spreadsheet so
anytime someone edits this cell I can
check if that cell is edited and then I
can call this HTTP and trigger so it was
actually a pretty cool front-end and it
exposed a lot of people in the room who
had come just to hear about IOT they got
to hear a little bit about sheets too
and a few people commented on it so I
was excited to see that people saw the
value in putting sheets as being a layer
and between kind of like technical teams
and like other teams at the company I
was actually gonna ask that it sounds
like this could be a really really
probably handy or possibly a quick way
of getting technical teams to talk to
like the business users and vice versa
and get that communication going is that
something you're actively like kind of
looking to do not precisely like I'm not
here to restructure how Google gets its
job done but one thing that's really
important to me is making it easier like
I said this whole like idea of
increasing productivity with clever and
useful solutions and so if I can explain
something to someone or if I can go to
your company we can give our
presentation for the whole day and like
walk you through it and show you how
simple tools like this make it easier
for knowledge to be exchanged that's not
that I I think is a huge value just
because being able to communicate with
other teams who have a slightly
different lingo is usually a barrier
right like trying to see what you each
need or what you each call it but then
if you have you know an interface like
this where it's like okay the
engineering side kind of set it up and
then the sales side can kind of ask for
what they need you actually learn a lot
more about how each person works which
can help you make decisions for future
growth or future data bases or new
projects or you know where to scale yeah
and in the like immediate gratification
aspect teams like IT teams or database
admin teams that are used to having to
take in requests and constantly pull
data for like a sales team or a business
analysis
you can build this tool they can still
pull the data from a tool that they are
used to so they can ask sheets for a
time slice of data from a fire store
database so it's a way to maybe reduce
some of your own workload for repeated
requests that's cool
I remember who was talking about it with
like a bigquery connector as well so you
get big data at as well so the bigquery
data connector to sheets several really
cool things I want to make sure I say
about this one Google recognizes that
these kinds of connections are popular
and also not everyone has time to build
their own so there's an effort and a
focus internally to make sure we provide
some services that would be really
really advantageous very large number of
customers that being said the bigquery
data connector is an example of one that
is like one of the differences between
consumer and enterprise things because
it would be part of like your a G suite
package but basically consider it as
like we did the work already for that
exact exchange so everything can be done
completely from the UI meaning nobody
has to be trained up on it nobody has to
tweak it no one in IT is stuck being the
one person who knows how to maintain the
tool from sheets you can do a couple of
clicks and you can be pulling data out
of your bigquery database even though
you don't really know how to explain to
anybody what a database is and that's
that's the kind of ease and simplicity
that we're going for because without
that you spin up your own and you have
to either understand the bigquery API or
you have to understand advanced services
an Apps Script and then that's just a
lot and I think I had used this before
because we have our data at Google and
in query and as a program manager I was
constantly trying to get you know Google
Analytics data or that sort of thing to
try to figure out effectiveness of our
programs and so I would use the button
and bigquery that's export to Google
sheets so you can in the bigquery UI you
can run a query you see your results and
you can export that to Google sheets
which I did all the time because I love
analyzing data in a sheets but now this
basically takes like a step out of the
process I no longer have to familiarize
myself with bigquery UI I don't have to
export it to a sheet I can actually just
from my sheet to connect to bigquery
pull my results my query results are in
a tab that has a refresh button so
anytime I want to refresh that data I
can refresh it and then I
and like connect it to other data in
that same spreadsheet or across other
spreadsheets and so it really makes it
possible to kind of access bigquery as
somebody that's a sheets user nice
are there other cloud of integrations
out there that you enjoy seeing or
you've seen that you're excited about
not necessarily an integration but an
opportunity that I saw this year that I
actually talked about I blogged about
was using our machine learning api's for
my Google sheet so with Apps repped I
can call any REST API and so seeing that
I had certain types of data in my sheet
that were hard to analyze just using
formula I was able to use our natural
language API from a sheet using Apps
Script to analyze text data in that
sheet so a common use cases people use
Google Forms to collect feedback you end
up with freeform feedback perhaps and a
Google sheet which is backing that form
and then normally you would just
manually read all of those reviews get a
sense of the data you might get super
fancy and make a word cloud but that's
about it so that's not super useful this
way I was able to take that feedback
send it over to our natural language API
have it extract out what people were
saying what they were talking about and
with what type of sentiment so using our
entity sentiment method of the natural
language API copy that data back into my
spreadsheet and then I could visualize
the data using you know in Google charts
or even out in data studio so it's not
necessarily an integration but it's a
way to how is that not an integration
knowledge like you integrated with the -
to build this a really cool demo and I
also like how well I'm not excited about
it that's one of my favorite demos this
year I talked about that demo all the
time I'm excited about her demo I plan
to continue talking about that demo for
as long as I can
I just did this thing with the ML API
isn't it kind of counts it's like no
this is one of the coolest things I can
think about and how many people want
that kind of analysis that like goes
beyond like a chart right yeah I do of
like I do some internal Google events
with like a lot of people and we get a
lot of freeform text response and like
being able to actually dig through that
in an automatic way is fantastic well
the codes available and github mark have
to include that link what about other
people that you've seen the work that
they've done it's not exactly cloud but
you could see how it could have been one
of the things that amuses me to no end
is I love how you both are couching it
well it's not exactly but it goes cloud
officially G suite NGC one of my
favorite co-workers he will just write a
script for anything like if something
bothers him twice he's scripting up a
solution to it that weekend and so he
has this whole automated app script that
he has that anytime he gets an email
from his child's daycare because they
email pictures but the pictures are only
like saved for 24 hours or whatever so
anytime he gets an email for his child
daycare it triggers the script it takes
the photo it copies it and saves it
locally into his drive and then he has
this album that's just like all of the
photos of his kids in daycare from like
daily update emails that were just meant
to be like hey guess what like they
didn't choke on a cheeto or whatever I
don't know how the kids do then like you
can see like a natural extension of that
is now you have years of school email
updates like how could you use some of
our like visual photo recognition or
image recognition kind of API is like to
make this something more useful or to
collate it or to grab the best ones for
like the holiday Christmas card
but like this is just like one guy who's
like why did these emails keep deleting
and he just fixes it and it didn't take
him long at all and that's the kind of
thing I love about Apps Script is just
whatever idea you have I bet you could
probably get it going in like a hacky
kinda way in about three hours and I
think another example that really I
think brings in to kind of the new
exciting stuff about GCP and cloud that
I haven't built but one of my co-workers
sent me an example of it was with the
Gmail API you can access all of your
different Gmail messages what you've
label
them so this was about kind of training
your own machine learning model to pre
label all of your emails so you can use
your past email labels you can train
that up and so then anytime you get a
new email it can pre label it for you so
I haven't built it but it seems we have
your next hackathon idea possible
especially with the Gmail API yeah
that's a why I have it maybe even [ __ ]
Auto ml I feel like might sound like a
pro tip would be use filters to apply
labels based upon like the kind of thing
coming in but filters can take so long
to set up if you haven't already been
using them so then it's like State gmail
make my filters for me I'm gonna write
that down I'll let show you're doing
that oh that's nice Estefan and by you I
mean we because you know I'm gonna help
this is why I don't come to meetings
exactly well thank you so much to both
you for coming before we wrap up is
there anything else you want to mention
or plug or you need any events or
anything like that that you want to make
sure that our listeners hear from you
about I'm planning on going to a few
deaf fest events so I'm hoping I think a
lot of the Google developer group
community talked a lot about all of our
different Google products but I want to
make sure G suite is represented well so
I'll be speaking at a few of those well
I'm very proud of you I intend to plant
my feet in Texas and not leave it so
don't look for me at conferences but I
do and there is one other point I wanted
to make sure I kind of touched on as we
talk about all these integrations
I was helping edit a blog post for the
GCP Friday series and I noticed and this
like really really awesome demo that
we've been putting together that if
you're working on an app script if your
workouts and it's gonna make something
easier for your employees or for the
people around you or they're gonna try
to sell you need to make sure it's
actually easier because if it's hard to
get it going it's no one's going to use
it right and so this whole demo was this
elaborate awesome thing and we were
really proud of it and it's a three part
blog series that I think the third part
comes out this week but it ended with in
order to run the whole thing you copy a
URL into the bar and you hit the URL in
point to trigger the function and I was
like this is not simpler this is like
one more thing to remember even though
does
for you and so I wrapped that for Martin
inside of a custom menu option so now in
the sheet for the demo the fake people
who totally exist or whatever they can
click them to custom any option and then
to hit the endpoint as easily as they
can file print and so when you're
designing things oh is this the series
with martin omander yeah this is with
martin yeah I was working with him on
this yeah we've been mentioning Italy's
community but yeah so if you are
designing something to make someone's
day easier think about how it will
actually be used try to think of it from
the no experience no context perspective
because if somebody knows from the sheet
I can copy the URL saved in that one
cell and go to it versus I can do the
equivalent of a file print that's a much
more successful integration and so just
always go that one step further like how
do I make this as simple as possible to
get it going and per tip it's usually
make a custom menu option yeah I always
offer for my teammates I'm like if you
need UX I can be your sample user sounds
like an offer for the whole world here
so just tweet her oh yes if you can find
me I have a very common name we have a
so every way to get you now well great
thank you again for both of you coming
on to the podcasts yeah thanks very much
for having us thanks again to Alicia and
Joanna I really like this episode I
think it's a really good I'm gonna say
the word synergy because it's bringing
together business users and developers
and it feels like that's actually a fit
now it's good to talk about especially
juice week it's something we use and
it's so accessible and we don't think
about how much effort that really goes
into building up these products and
making them seem lessen yeah yeah I want
to write a whole batch script to
automate a bunch of things should write
a lot of app script
good job all right mark the question of
the week what if I want to write a code
sample with a link that opens the cloud
console and automatically clones a git
repository into cloud shell yeah so I'm
actually really excited about this I
think it's really cool I think you know
the classic example is maybe you're
writing a code lab or you have an
open-source project that you want
someone just get started with quickly
and you wanted it to be able to open up
in an environment that has like the
g-cloud tools and all the other things
become available with cloud shell and
you just want to be quick and easy
there's actually a link format that is
described in the link that will put in
here called opening cloud shell is the
feature where you can set URL parameters
for like the git repo what git branch
working directory whether you wanted to
be opened in web editor as well you can
also send instructions to this class
shell print values optional tutorial
markdown file basically if you want to
build like a really quick start like hey
get this thing going
you can basically just write this link
and it's kind of Awesome that's like
it's basically the link to cloud console
cloud shell editor with some your
parameters and boom you're good to go
good yeah mark my understanding is
you'll be at cube Con in December is
that right that is indeed correct I will
be a cue cone talking about - hopefully
I said that vaguely correctly so I'm
pretty excited about that first time
going and then I'll be at so Kamal at
the end of November so that's where
you'll find us next other than in San
Francisco or Australia Australia I'll be
going home forbid going for a break all
right mark I think that gives us a nice
regular wrap for the week sounds good
well Melanie thank you for joining me
for yet another week in this podcast
thank you Mark and thank you all for
listening and we'll see you all next
week
[Music]